nathan you've missed so much  the town's revamped my 18th birthday i  did send you that cameo from olivia  rodrigo's horse that horse did not phone  it in i love an animal who knows her  angles  regan i really need your help nathan he  had a little bit of a rough patch  but adversity makes us stronger no  wreaks is this sweater too sexy for what  what about a vest  welcome to the new minnesota cultural  center this is nelson my co-curator  you're touching those with bare hands  would you want to be touched with hands  covered in gloves you don't know what  i'm into man nice to see you miss fish i  listen to that podcast about you i have  josh's info if you want to dox him well  i find that troubling  hey terry regan's in a res fight oh tell  her if she hits the ground it's over  listen matriarch to matriarch  [Music]  that is bonker donkers  [Music]  you